all right everybody it's time for the
most awaited and sometimes most dreaded
moment of the week it's time for the
mailbag email us info davidpakman.com
uh spammers and people who abuse the
email
just get auto filtered into the trash
it's a sad thing but it does happen some
people email us every day multiple times
a day don't do it nobody's going to read
it it'll just get you banned
let's just jump right in though because
there are messages that i would not
describe as being messages of peace and
love
user no bs wrote in
and said why don't you go back to
argentina
and complain about your own country and
start a show to divide it
you're a weak
pathetic
beta male who sold his soul and show for
a leftist organization for money you're
an perfect example that's right you're
an perfect example of everything that is
wrong with the world today
satan
is your daddy
i take issue
with the fact
that we sold the show
for a leftist organization or to a
leftist organization for money
many have claimed we are soros funded
it's thinly veiled anti-semitism guys
people claim we're funded by the dnc i'm
not even a democrat the nc has never
never given us anything
um
just for once
putting the xenophobia of go back to
argentina aside for a moment just for
once i would love to see a single one of
these claims
backed up with even a cintilla
of data
i'm ready to hear it
if you've got it to present
next one this this is a bonus from
facebook i love this
this one actually has a big backstory
someone wrote to me and said cut your
show today and it's all entirely opinion
not news just fyi
now a lot of people write this
because
they
have such lack of media literacy
that they seem to think
i believe i do a news show now as all of
you know if you've been listening to the
show or watching it for any period of
time
you know
that i accurately
characterize this program
uh as an opinion show
this is an opinion show and if any of
you have seen my sort of knowledge
pyramid where
if we want to be informed about the
world shows like mine should be
equivalent to the junk food they're more
entertainment
that hopefully gives you ideas and forms
that gets you thinking we need to have
at the bottom of our pyramid it's funny
you know it's sort of the opposite of of
like religious doctrine where it's like
we have the answers it's the opposite of
trump saying i alone can fix it my view
is
we should all have as a baseline
epistemology critical thinking
media literacy and philosophy that's our
baseline
that then allows us to go and read and
learn about history and political
science we take our knowledge of
knowledge
and we go and we study these areas
history economics all these different
things
the next
q quad piece of the pyramid
is
news reporting actual reports associated
press etc
and then after all that once you're well
versed in knowing how did i know how do
i come to know the things i believe and
studying what has happened in the past
and economic theory and seeing what's
going on
then you throw commentary and opinion
programs that you like on top of that
that's always been my position it's
almost like i'm trying to put myself out
of business but in any case it's funny
when someone writes in and goes your
program is not news it's opinion i
thought you should know that oh believe
me i know the fact that so many people
don't know is the problem we have in
this country
next email is from don don wrote in
about covid deaths
don said dear david please refrain from
your weekly reports on notable
unvaccinated people dying from covid any
fool can point out that many fully
vaccinated people also have died from
cobit and your one-sided exuberance
makes you appear petty and thoughtless
um
i have never been exuberant about
unvaccinated people dying from coven
bring that to some other show done
because that's a garbage allegation
in every segment i say for me these
aren't funny segments these are not i
don't this isn't good so tell us someone
else goes on to say you may not care and
perhaps you receive all critique as
being some political assault but you
really should take a moment and think
about how your well-earned reputation as
a reasonable commenter can become
sullied yours truly done well don if you
were making a criticism that was
connected to the facts that i'm
exuberant about these people dying that
would be one thing as i've said before
yes vaccinated people sometimes die your
likelihood of dying if you are fully
vaccinated is orders of magnitude lower
than if you are not and the reason that
we point out these stories is the
defiance with which some of these people
say i don't need to worry
only exists among the anti-vaccines the
people who go and get vaccinated
recognize even if i'm not likely to get
very sick i want the protection
why did i go and get my three doses
because i know i'm not likely to get
very sick but why chance it i wear my
seat belt i use winter tires
i would take the suit of armor if i walk
through a forest with arrows flying and
so the point here is
the defiance with which to the very end
they continue to spread anti-vaxx and
then they die and they are unvaccinated
i completely take issue with the
characterization from dawn
todd wrote in about the last week we
looked at this segment where a an
anti-vaxx right-winger model actress
type person
said that when she goes near vaccinated
people she has rectal bleeding
and i said that could be very serious
todd wrote in and said pacman i've
researched the strange anal bleeding the
poor woman is experiencing when around
vaccinated people
my research concludes it's a new form of
stigmata if you air this on your show
please don't play pizzas here or we have
kentucky fried chicken in the background
i don't know i don't even know what that
means but uh yeah if i googled stigmata
i didn't know what it was apparently
it's various sores and bleeding
considered to be associated with some
kind of religious belief it's some kind
of punishment some
stigmata is like
if for sinning or something or satan
someone does it anyway it's uh yeah
given that many of these people are
christians you would think maybe they
would they would chalk it up to uh to
stigmata got another message alexa has
decided it doesn't like david pakman
greetings for the last few days asking
alexa to play the david pakman show the
latest episode
brings up techno music
i listened to it for a couple minutes
yesterday to make sure you hadn't
changed your opening music unless you're
opening with an extended cut i think the
alexa programming has gotten screwed up
i don't use slash have alexa if anybody
in the audience can replicate this if
you can get a video of asking alexa to
play the latest episode and it playing
techno please record it and send it to
info davidpakman.com we would really
like to see that that that sounds
absolutely hilarious
devin wrote in now by the way
for all the criticisms of david you're
an opinion show you're not a news show
um i always want to issue corrections
when they are warranted
devin corrected me about pcr tests let's
look at what devin said hello david sir
i was watching one of your recent videos
on youtube where you were discussing pcr
tests for covid and you mentioned that
the pcr tests detect viral proteins i
did say that devin writes this is
technically incorrect covid pcr tests
detect the presence of viral rna
i know you pride yourself on
disseminating correct information i
figured you'd want to know you were
right devin i did want to know love the
show keep up the good work thank you
thank you
um
coveted pcr detects the presence of
viral rna
i stand corrected
and i bow at the altar
of the audience
and apologize
the rest of the analysis was correct in
terms of the meaning the diagnostic
value of a pcr test which has become
unfortunately the subject of yet more
conspiracy theories
lastly ryan wrote in and says sir david
david sir
have been a member almost as long as
i've been listening almost a year now
greatly appreciate your calm and honest
delivery of the daily topics keep doing
what you do we all appreciate it not all
you should see my inbox but i appreciate
the sentiment over the long weekend i
was listening to some of your old
interviews while i appreciate the
productive sane interviews i've got to
say the ones with quote religious people
are probably the most entertaining for
example the david manning interview is
just a total gem absolutely hilarious i
suggest the listeners check it out as
well thanks for your work happy new year
ryan thank you ryan yeah we keep sort of
going back and forth about the value of
doing the wacky interviews
a few months ago we did one with amanda
mackie and she was pretty cuckoo for
cocoa puffs it it does very well
but the reason i've gotten away from it
is partially it's less entertaining for
me like yes these people are bonkers
they're ignorant i get it
but they're so predictable
that i've been more going in the
direction of talking to
journalists writers investigators
doctors etc
um and number two
i don't know i know some people in the
audience like it some don't so i i'm as
i've said before
we'll continue to sprinkle in the
interviews with the wacky people
but
i've explained a little bit of why i've
sort of gotten away from it over the
last few years
if you have a question for me a comment
a thought whatever you can write into
info
davidpakman.com remember that if you
want to get more show
every day you should sign up for a
membership at joinpackman.com producer
pat is back from his vacation he will be
back on the friday bonus show as your
regularly scheduled programming has led
you to expect we will see you on the
bonus show
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below